so this is the tax plan
comparing bidens against trumps
okay trump 21
biden 28 this is the worst worst case it
can be on top and it's the one on the
bottom
that trump is focusing on and saying
that the stock market's going to crash
so out of the four you're looking at
income tax and payroll
it's going to go to 37. uh biden's 52
small business tax 296396
capital gains 2 23 8 43 4. pull up the
50 cent thing that he did on new york
post he said
62.6 percent in the state of cali state
of uh new york
uh i know california and 60 in new york
and then 50 cent comes out saying i
don't
want to be known as 20 cent under
biden's tax plan says i don't care about
trump i just don't want to pay the taxes
so when you look at these taxes go back
to the numbers everybody can take a look
at it
when you go back to these tax a matter
of fact make that bigger make us smaller
make that bigger
make us smaller what's going to hurt the
economy the most out of these four
immediately the capital gains tax why is
that
well if people if if if if there's a
certain biden victory
in 2000 in 2020 then people who are
sitting on a ton of gains on their
in their stock holdings they're going to
take those gains off the table they're
going to they're going to take a much
lower capital gains hit than they will
if they wait until 2021. that's the
biggest risk right now to the stock
market
i'll unpack that again okay so if this
is i'm going to pay a lower tax rate
today
this year which means high we've only
got a few weeks left of this year
effectively versus taking the risk that
they pass that capital gains tax hike
quickly such that i would be i would
lose what
20 percentage points of my gains wow so
lots
of people are going to sell and get out
of the stock market before they win
is that is that investors are sitting on
such a huge also you said
if they pass this before he's even
inaugurated they're going to get
hammered
because they're not going to take a
chance no no no no no taxes aren't going
to go up
if biden wins nothing happens in lame
duck nada
no time out you just said people are
going to dump it within weeks that's
going to affect the stock market in 2020
right because people aren't going to
wait and see if it passes or not that's
what i'm saying
in 2021 it's not like it's going to come
back up in 2021 well it's the most
overvalued
it's been in the history of the country
so no it's not yeah so there are
other economic factors like 23 million
americans collecting unemployment
benefits that are dragging
the economy down all by itself so that's
number one how does this affect
so for example i i have the answer for
myself but i want to hear from you
somebody that's in this space you're
right billionaires subscribe to quote if
you've not
uh uh you know we put a link to below to
what she does in the comment section
people want to know what she really does
on how much i'll call danielle we'll
talk we'll be talking to pat i'm writing
all day today can we talk thursday and
we'll get on the phone we'll talk the
next i know
the days for us to talk this thursday
because she's working non-stop writing
but for me i want you to kind of explain
this from the standpoint of
i'm the small business owner how does
this affect me i'm an average guy i
don't run a business i make fifty five
thousand dollars a year
how does that affect me i'm an
independent contractor making three
hundred thousand dollars a year how does
this affect me
give us all you're going to look if
you're if your take-home profits
go back up to the prior peak rate 39.6
is what it was prior
to the trump tax bill if you're if you
know that then you're going to be more
reticent about
expanding your workforce to the same
extent you're not going to make the same
invest
investment you might other otherwise
because you're going to look at the
profit picture and you're looking you're
going to look at
the math of profits differently given
what you know you can take home from
that
so it's going to make you a potentially
more conservative
small business owner which is the last
thing we need at this juncture
with so many small businesses that have
already been lost so danielle question
for you
because you said you were not sure who
you're voting for i'm still not
is seeing something like this this
doesn't sway you
to want to vote more towards trump and
why not
well then it comes down to an
existential question right then it comes
down to
why you would vote for one person over
the other whether or not you were doing
something that was bigger for your
country
and that is i think where the people who
are undecided
why they're undecided i i was out to
dinner with with some friends a few
nights ago this lovely open air west
village blah blah blah area here in
dallas
and he said i've voted republican my
entire life and i know that
i know that i'm going to be paying
higher taxes
and yet i think it's the right thing to
do to vote against
trump and so i think that that is where
some
people have their thinking because they
they view trump as being a divisive
president rather than being a uniting
president again
is he devised okay so here's a question
because
i mean he was asked about the the the
the governor of michigan and he said
you know they're they're chanting lock
her up and he's like no lock them all
up so i mean you you have to be more
like tonight
you have to be more like that trump more
presidential yes more tactful
would you please repeat that and unpack
that because i was picking up a spill
you said the guy was lifelong republican
lifelong republican he'd always voted
for the republican party his entire life
he knew that it was going to cost him
money in higher taxes because of the
type of company that he
has so he knew he's in real estate but
he knew that he was going to
be paying higher taxes but yet he felt
that
it was the right thing to do for the
country i could not wrap around
my arms around that thought that it was
unbelievable that he would say that
and then you couple coronavirus right so
if we have riots in our streets and we
have a lot of people who connect
very quick dots to it to the fires in
the streets
the lincoln project you've heard of this
lincoln project is basically all former
nationalistic all republicans all
republicans
they're former they're former republican
campaign advisers
securities staunched on gop they've come
out there's hundreds of them how many
who've all come out and said i can't
support this person i had a conversation
with a person on the dnc he's a major
fundraiser and he makes it beaucoup a
lot of money and i was like dude
you make a lot of money tell me how you
justify voting
democrat when you know that it's going
to increase your taxes he said kind of
like danielle said
it's bigger than mine bigger than me
it's bigger than me
and that is me
what do you mean what do you mean this
is what i want to know what's the
okay it's bigger i don't know what
you're talking about explain to me
what's the bigger what do i assume they
want to care about
the com the country benefiting over
higher taxes
higher taxes solution with china
obviously selling yourself to china
having your son i think they're talking
about i think it's simpler than that i
think it's what's on the evening news
okay that's what i'm talking about so
it's not bigger
people just assume it's bigger well it
is look it's not big but wait where she
went
wait wait wait was she why have gun
sales in america tripled
since the corona virus i know i know our
household has more because
we are scared of the narrative the
democrats keep pushing but i i speak to
my friends
on the east coast in new york in new
york city these are
these are die hard liberals and they're
they're they're gunning up and i'm like
god you're going to shoot your foot off
i mean i get it here i get it here in
texas
the whole country is getting warmed up
i've been in beverly hills i've seen the
riots i've seen the stuff going on i
mean the reason
people are buying i've never owned a gun
in my life ever
i'm gonna get a gun i am going to get a
gun
i live in l.a i i mean and it's not the
it's the stuff i see what's going on for
real there's stuff they didn't even talk
about on the debate tonight
very very important what she said
because we were having a conversation
today and he says
pat if the taxes adam's asking me when i
landed back from i was at jekyll island
last four days i had a whole meeting
there anyways
so so i'll he said pat how about all
these tax stuff you know if that's the
case
why are all these silicon valley people
voting for the left okay
why are all these billion and then we
address that why is wall street why is
wall street voting for the left and so
and wall street i don't know that they
are we don't know exactly how they vote
but he's asking the question
but you said something you said
something right now and then
you said and he says well how about this
how about collusion how about raising
taxes how about your son this and he
went off right
and you said i don't think it's that
complicated i think it's as simple as
what's being said on the news
what the no no not what's being said you
can have it on mute with what you're
seeing on the news with the fires in the
streets i think that that says more than
anything else
it's like it's picturesque
it's it's not necessarily the truth
that's manipulation
adam said he talked to his buddy the dnc
and he says it's bigger
what's bigger the lies so you've got to
go and put somebody that's going to make
everybody happy so that you stop the
riots that's not bigger
that's you saying i'm i'm scared i don't
know how to defend my country
and i'm just going to sit here and cry
about it and i'm just going to put
somebody's going to give us peace
but it's literally going to ruin the
country so it's not bigger
that's if there's a blue sweep if it's i
don't know
if it's a blue sweep if it's not a blue
streak the legislation doesn't get you
i'm going to
make this super freaking simple beyond
simple okay
why are half the country for trump
and why is half the country against
trump not even this super simple it's
not naivete
i i i'm letting you know if you want if
you're willing to listen
half the country loves trump because
he's an [ __ ]
because he shakes things up no no
because he'll call [ __ ] because
he'll call out china
and the other half of the country hates
him because he's an [ __ ]
it's just that simple no
[Music]